all right so I'm going to define a
moment for you okay so if you have that
last set and I reach out and I catch
okay reach out and I catch that catches
so do it again boom Reach Out
catch Reach Out catch One More Time Boom
Reach Out
catch catch okay so let's look at it a
little slower so one I have to reach for
it I have to make contact with it but as
it starts to push on me now a little
slower I start to now bring myself into
its direction okay same thing again slow
I reach for it and as it starts to push
on me I go in this direction and then
rotate the
cross one more time couple of things I
reach and I
yield reach
yield okay in
contrast well here I'm just hitting it
from the side hit it from the
side with that you can see I don't reach
for
it I don't reach for it so at the
beginning if you watch my tip it's not
there
boom boom it's not there it's over there
boom
okay so there's a moment
where I'm going to reach for It Go in
this
direction and then I'm going to now be
not conflicting with it but depending on
what I want to do adhere to it or
project on it okay so
here is your going his Direction he's
pushing
me there's a a catch up okay and the
particular type of catch I'd like you to
work is the
qua going
down
under so I'm not here and leaning
back but I'm
going under
it and I don't know if it's visible
maybe from the
side and maybe you can see it here okay
so I'm going to go under it almost like
a tilt and it allow my
shoulders to move from this
plane slightly back you see without
having to do like that which is going to
make me hold my breath okay so I'm going
under and my shoulders will move back so
we go
slow under that was all I need now now
you can feel my round path right
okay and because I'm going with his
energy I I don't need to be stiff up
here I go with it and this is the new
[Music]
ground okay let's see what we get so
this cach is good this quad movement
here is good when I'm going to do both
both arms
okay and both
arms I think this way
[Music]
too doesn't matter if after you here you
turn you're catching on the vertical
play and so it allows you to not
[Music]
contest okay try all right so there is
some movement that you can see like as
you watch my shoulder are coming back
okay um but if you're if you have a lot
of tension in your hands and you have a
lot of T even if you come back you get
kind of stuck there a lot of weight on
your hands right there you feel that
okay so your hands have to be very
relaxed and that's what you as you move
into that space you want that okay so
they're very relaxed very relaxed very
relaxed oh see I I tensed up there
when I push on you you push on me okay
so I have to be very relaxed very
relaxed
okay um the next one will catch on one
side so you can catch on the quad catch
on the shoulder release if you're going
to catch on one side here work on that
side you see I
work catch the other
side
and of course you can't combine the two
so I start with one and then I catch on
the other
side and catch
here both one
side okay and what you want to do with
this catch is uh I want to catch it for
you to land on the CQ okay as opposed to
we do this stuff here and then I press
into the C okay on
these I land
you okay and let's so let's we're going
to catch we're going to mix the two
catching techniques but we want them to
land on the C okay projection
so there's you feel the pressure like
you're pushing on my ground Vector okay
now I'm going to catch you see and I now
take that pressure there you feel it's
right it's there but I'm not positive y
to you okay and so normally what we do
is we push on
that I get positive y the same thing the
yield and then we
push and sometimes you push with your
hand so your he your hand comes down
okay but what we're trying to do now is
he's going to Boom it'll be positive y
here okay so
in
there you can see I don't need to make
my arm come out I don't need to go
forward he just lands on
it okay that's what we're trying to do
catch him and land him in the projection
Point okay try it again to the other
half so
cokan is going here so you guys see
there it's going I'm going underneath it
and then I yield it there okay and then
that's
it so I'm not going to
go under it
yield and then
around and that's just where he land so
if you pay
attention it's still still in the
yielding position
okay um so when I yield over here you
can
see it's drawing a trajectory that
way so I need
you to be in this
position so that that Force line
works you guys see that so you have to
go across it and then there's my X line
you
see so as as I go here boom this is
where you you see and so it's projecting
and IT projects that
way okay so that means this hand has to
do something can't do whatever it has to
get you there so again I go underneath
on the yield you see and then it has to
bring you there then this and in this
position can do its
projection so sometimes you're like I'm
stopping you you see you feel that this
one's yielding but that one's stopping
you and then you can't ever get there
and so now I got to make it go
completely over something else so on
this yield hand it goes like that you
see look how much you came forward so
yield hand goes
around okay do you guys see that the
can't go here I cut down I'm going to
stop your progress you see you can't
come forward so I don't cut down I just
get out of the way of that hand I never
do any I don't catch it get out of the
way of
it to
release there's that wrong you feel
[Music]
it
okay so this one I catch and I'm going
to be here now okay so again you can see
I have these if I'm catching right I can
get oh over the top you see I can get
over the top okay I'm catching wrong I
can't I can't okay so here I'm doing one
yield on the other side and then I catch
over
here
okay you can
see again don't make this mistake and
stop him he has to be able to
fall in a way you're bringing him onto
that hand
okay got it so this hand a
under
yields boom is when he hits the hand is
helping him come onto that okay let's
try here's the hand and what we're doing
is using your arm make a fist okay and
I'm using your arm to go
around this is what I'm doing so but
instead of staying here and I move my
shoulder I move my qua move my shoulder
and I come back around so if you look
down here there's a lot of movement okay
so I using your grip right and that's
what's making me do that so I get all
the way around to the top okay and then
of course you have the
okay so that's look down here okay like
there's a lot of
movement oh I want to focus on this hand
on you cuz it has to do the same thing
so I don't want to cut here as I start
cutting you you can't come forward even
if I even if you let go right you're not
going to come
forward so what's happen happening is
there's no movement over here you see
and then I can't get over your arm you
see the press the pressure is right
there so this arm this has to move so I
get all the way over it you see all the
way over it and if you pay attention
Okay so I go up down or right let's plot
your head in space from where you wor
right and then the other
one you see
you get it okay so the
two are moving in this right here okay
where you hit
it okay and I
can't I can't do
that if your young isn't at a higher
value okay like for
example uh if you stay there
okay and you can feel it but there's
nothing happening to your body do you
see no the young your young value is so
low it's stuck there you see like if you
let go it's stuck but there's not enough
to project you okay so I get out of your
way so now the Y value has increased
here such that I don't have to move it
in order to to rebound you you
understand right okay so that that's
what you have to do by getting out of
the
way okay and the more you stop
him you're reducing the Y value you're
going to have
to generate it by your movement okay all
right